in their previous episode
and the epic story continues here's a
good one
everyone my name is pewdiepie ching
chong [ __ ] welcome back to cat
mario
episode 2 i bet you weren't expecting
that a lot of you bros
wanted me to play more of this you
[ __ ] dicks fish
there you go now we go down that [ __ ]
yolo whoa dude
[Laughter]
we actually kept the level design on the
ash
good good good see this game is not that
difficult
your brother said it's difficult i'm
like girl there's a trap here for sure
that's what's gonna fall i didn't expect
it
what the [ __ ]
they just had to throw in cat pedo [ __ ]
no not that fun we're fine
you tell me yeah you [ __ ] tell me how
am i playing even
why did it why didn't [ __ ] fine
yes yes where is that [ __ ] thing
there you are you little [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you for another one stop
okay there's a [ __ ] flag there i
intend to take it yes i have this game
ah enough how the [ __ ] do i dodge that
thing
what what how the [ __ ] am i supposed to
do
that wait i got it i got it i think i
got it now
yolo yolo look at that
[Music]
so hope you enjoyed mario i'm not
competitive
oh cat mario i underestimated you didn't
i
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
hey i gotta make a gaming paint i'm
gonna call it cat mario
and i'm gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] people in the
ass
i bet a guy with no dick made this so
you could [ __ ] people are you angry
you don't even know the the pinnacle of
my hatred
what is that from there's even a shadow
of my hatred
it's from uh [ __ ] i have no mouth but
i can't scream swag
don't say yolo [ __ ] yoda i can feel
this
comic [ __ ] ass
what the [ __ ]
okay i don't know what to do
mario you don't talk my parents are
you don't respect
we're fine we're fine we're fine we're
fine
we're fine we're fine look at that
so how do you do this how do you how to
no that is not how you do this
i'm screwed [ __ ] you
the control is like handling a dick
you know i don't know how what it's like
i'm just assuming chase
yeah yeah yeah
okay no traps here
oh that's a question mark i came so far
i don't know
i'll take it yolo right what the [ __ ]
did i just do it more balls
really [ __ ] really yeah there's no
way now
okay balls are not gonna [ __ ] me this
time
no balls no balls no bad balls
bad balls i do not want to touch you
stop
stop it how the hell okay i'm going for
it
yeah what's up all right i don't trust
your platforms
[ __ ] it i'm going anyway what's up
what's up
what take them
all right i have not yet been [ __ ] by
the balls and i don't plan
to eat all night i got [ __ ] by the
bars
and i liked it don't trust you okay okay
okay everyone just [ __ ] stop
everything what you're doing
i want some hardcore time before you
brothers that's right do it like this do
it like this
just don't stop don't take it too too
good
i'm just gonna [ __ ] go for it bam
bam nail that [ __ ] that no no no no
no no bad kitty it's you and me flag
okay you know what i'm gonna try that i
bet i'm just gonna have to
what the [ __ ]
no no yes yes
[Laughter]
how about no how about what the [ __ ]
happened
[Music]
okay that's great great
going down yolo right up
yo [ __ ] [ __ ] what do i do with the
coins
anyway what's the [ __ ] point what do
you do
well so many coins wow that's a lot of
those
coins oh yes
let me get this straight get a [ __ ]
coins and then the game kills you
is that is that is that it that is this
bravo oh okay okay okay
okay
why are they so mean look at this
look at this look at that look at it
look at it
your [ __ ] face what's wrong with your
face man are you an octopus or a kitty
cat
i don't know go for it kitty cat
oh
ah well
how about that how
i love this game this is like the best
game ever
i would give you 10 10 games out of 10
yes what what the hell is the parking
lot
i should not have done that oh
oh good thing i got money that's
why you do with it okay do not touch
edge
and then up edge okay yolo
[Music]
i'm a lad i'm in love jesus
praise the jesus oh
i'm on the [ __ ] roll get mario okay
mario
oh
your name and name
[Applause]
[Music]
all right all right so here i'm going to
bouncy
oh oh all right so we're going to bounce
it down the question is if i should just
[ __ ] yolo
yolo ah yolo is the answer to everything
kids
write that down